The Joe Rogan Experience I was very lost
and very alone and I was like on like
day six or something of being lost I
don't remember
um now it wasn't that long of a solo but
I was lost and I was scared how did you
get lost
well as soon as you leave the river
like you could literally walk 15 feet
and then be like I'm just gonna come
right back
and the jungle will like blare with you
you will you because it's all green so
you just like think you know what you're
doing just like just last week I took
people I wanted to cross from one Trail
to another trail and I was like I'm a
guide I can do this
came back out on the same Trail like a
half hour later and I was like yup
that's what I meant to do let's go like
like it happens to JJ all the time
really you cannot find your way in the
gym use a compass don't use a compass
um why not
uh because actually apparently some of
the iron content and some of the saps in
the trees pulls the needle it doesn't
work really well like
um the trees are trying to trick you oh
my god um GPS has run out of batteries
you know it's like it's like you really
just you have to learn your your your
Bushcraft you have to learn how to
navigate in the jungle and it's like
which is pretty much you have to get
just amazing at dead reckoning and and
remembering your your course because
it's so dense that like we play with
people we go you know go see if you can
go from here to there it's like they
can't they can't go there they can't do
that as soon as you leave the river so
like I had gone out on this solo
gotten lost gotten scared and then been
like oh [__] what if I just like into
the wild did myself what if now I'm yeah
I'm gonna be the next kid they went and
died in the Amazon and like
I like slept in a in this in the hammock
but this is like as I was learning so I
didn't realize that the the hammock that
I had bought I had a mosquito net on top
but the back was not mosquito proof so
they could stick through so my back was
being destroyed by mosquitoes as I'm
trying to sleep and like a couple of
nights of that and so I finally fall
asleep and I wake up in the middle of
the night and I hear
breathing right next to my face
and I like wanted to turn my headlamp on
and I just hear like
right here like I could feel her breath
and I was like six inches away from a
Jaguar's face and she just like you know
and then left
and she just came in she wanted to see
what that was she was like you're not
gonna move that's what you're not gonna
do she growled like right into my ear
and then later on
but that one's cute though that's a cute
picture that's a cute Jack
wow and they vary in in colors and the
the spots and everything right like some
of them are much darker yeah well I mean
yeah actually somebody recently was like
um where do you see Panthers and I went
on this whole thing of like you know a a
leopard or a Jaguar just like you can
have albinos you have a melanistic one
yeah wow so like people would call that
a panther but a panther's not not a real
there's no animal that's a panther it's
like a Kleenex it's like it's a it's
just another name for it that is so
beautiful
yeah oh my God that's beautiful yeah in
South India they have the black leopards
what an amazing looking animal look at
the muscles yeah that's an amazing
killing machine
and so
humans don't get taken out by them
uh I can only really speak for our
region of the Amazon but there's I
haven't even heard a story about it
really no one like no one our Jags are
just we have like record numbers of Jags
like I think they're listed as near
threatened and we have like some of the
strongest remaining Jaguar populations
in the world
it's incredible I can barely see them we
barely see them
um the last one I saw was two years ago
and some people like go their whole
lives without seeing them really yeah
yeah yeah well because people walk off
into the jungle and they don't realize
people
people it's so funny living in the wild
and seeing people show up there and it's
like people come and they're like they
smell like shampoo and cologne and bug
spray and deodorant and they're just
like if to an animal that has such
better senses than we do
they might as well just have like sirens
on them and like you are this shiny
glittering fog horn of attention in the
jungle and like every animal is going to
run away from you and so people are
always like how come you go out and you
see so much stuff and it's like I only
shower in the river I live out in the
jungle I smell like they do like I'm out
there for weeks and it's like I'm not
going and like shampooing my hair it's
like
and so like to these animals like they
know when you're coming like a Jag's
just going to be like oh there's a human
there do you wash with soap when you
wash in the river I do I do I do use a
biodegradable soap you have to keep your
skin clean or else you just get
infections but like for the most part
like my clothing everything like I don't
use anything that's scented because of
that because I want to be out there and
and just blend in and that's whether I'm
out in the field with elephants or
whether you're out you know in Africa or
India or whether you're in the Amazon I
I want to be sort of like included I
want to blend in and so like not that
long ago I was checking a camera trap
and I heard I thought it was a we had
students at that at our research station
at the time and I heard like the leaves
going
it was like September so the jungle was
dry and I turned around and I was going
to scare this person because I was gonna
be like who walks that loud in the
jungle like have you never you have no
respect and I turned around with my
finger up and this Jag walked right by
me on the trail and just like what's up
I just kept walking and I was like
oh I grew up and I was like okay oh Lord
but I took that as good because at least
I was my my like scent Trail was was so
that he didn't know I was there I could
see it on his face he didn't care he was
like okay
but I mean it was six feet away he
didn't even break his stride he just
walked by me was like yo what's up
they don't think of you as food so they
just keep moving no and I think they're
you know with big cats they're the
mothers teach the young how to hunt and
I think they're so oriented like with
tigers they're so oriented on horizontal
you know get the neck from underneath
break the neck from up top and it's like
when they see a vertical animal walking
by I think they're like first of all I
don't know what this is second of all it
smells weird third of all where do I
even
you know you got to be desperate to take
that risk
um I don't think that I don't think that
they lions are a different story but but
with Jags with tigers with leopards
I don't I I've never ever felt any fear
being around a Jaguar like any fear I
don't even take pictures of them I just
enjoy it wow I let other people take
pictures if I'm with people let them
take pictures but I will not lift my
camera for a jack I'll just stand there
and just
take it in yeah you get to see him so
rarely I don't want to sit there finally
seeing one and then put another screen
in front of my face right look through
it through some glass like
whoa yeah yeah that's our camera that's
from yours yeah wow
what an amazing animal
glowing eyes
well that's the crazy thing you shine
your headlamp into the into the night
and then when things look back at you
you got to wonder what it is
it's like
well when there's two eyes in the front
you know yeah but some sometimes the
deer but then the Jags do this thing
where they move their head like this
they're like they try and see around
your headlamp they'll like do this
little side to side thing like the deer
they'll just blink at you they'll just
blink and so you start learning the eye
shines you start learning the
you know because then you can be out
there at night you look at something and
people like oh [__] dude it's a dragon
it's like no it's a deer when you were
saying that the uncontacted tribe or
speaking in Monkey calls yeah how do
they what are they doing
so JJ's dad
used to tell us he said if you're ever
out in the forest and
something doesn't sound right he was
like get out of there and he was like
because they will use the tinumu calls
like the unrelated Cinema was like
but like we know what that sounds like
but we also know what it doesn't sound
like and so like every now and then
you'll hear one that's you know
different and like we all get freaked
out because we're like those are that's
how we do it that's how JJ taught me to
do it like if there was a bunch of
tourists right there and JJ wanted me to
come over and like chill with him and we
wanted to go hang he would just do that
and get my attention and like I know
that it's not a tinum I know it's JJ and
so it's like they've taken that to a
whole nother level where they can
communicate and so there's a group of
guys who was upriver
and they got surrounded they heard
monkey calls coming from different
directions and they realized they were
completely surrounded like at least one
of the guys was saying was telling it to
me he got in the water and like crawled
like a turtle and like escaped and then
the tribe showed up and then there's
this whole Showdown where they they
actually shot one of the community
members and then one of the guys who
knows some of their language was saying
that they it looked like they were mad
with the guy that shot the guy they were
mad with him like they were like why did
you do that now there's going to be
retaliation like why did you shoot him
and like there was like a whole
discussion happening while these people
were like huddled in the Stream waiting
to see if they got killed too
so it's like I don't really on you know
because when you get these loggers going
in there it's like yeah we'll pay you to
protect the rainforest and like you
don't have to do this you don't have to
be going into these these areas
that are that dangerous
um so yeah so at this point now though
part you know through all of this though
we've established jungle Keepers we have
50 000 Acres we're trying to do 300 000
acres and if we can do that
will basically be helping to establish
one of the largest protected areas in
the Amazon rainforest which will
Encompass these uncontacted people and
they can stay uncontacted and they can
stay safe and do whatever they want to
do in the jungle
guarding the secret pyramids in the
giant ground sloths or whatever the hell
it is that they do
um
but we're close now how many unconducted
tribes are they aware of I think there's
like over a hundred different groups
across the Amazon
there's also varying degrees of and the
other thing is the conversation so often
gets turned to like their you know
um violent and that they're people to
live out in the jungle and I have no
idea how they do it either because you
know at night we need headlamps we don't
have
night vision all the animals have night
vision so it's like what do they do that
night they they're able to make fire in
the jungle at night every day
you if I gave you an entire book of
matches me and you we sat down right now
in the jungle I was like okay cool you
got a machete and a book of matches
first one to make fire wins
we couldn't do it
it's wet everything is wet so how are
they what are you know what's their are
they doing bow drill are they doing what
are they doing well no we don't really
know no
we don't know how they do that we don't
know how they stay infection free we
don't know what they do with their old
people we never see old people we never
really see children
and so like they move around and they we
see like groups of men on beaches we see
like that picture that aerial picture
where you see like a family group out
that's in Turtle season where you have
Turtles laying their eggs on the beaches
and the tribes will come out because
that's easy food you just pick up turtle
eggs and eat them
but there's so much that we don't know
about their lifestyle and like people
get so many things wrong just you know
if you leave them alone then they won't
kill you if you you know then people go
there's Stone Age tribes and it's like
well they're not Stony tribes because
they're they're alive right now
and you couldn't live out in the jungle
but they can right so it's like there's
elements of their
you know their their Botanical knowledge
their medicinal knowledge their creation
myths their view of history I mean
they're coming to reality from a whole
different perspective than we are wow
a way to get does anyone speak their
language do we know what language they
all speak is it Universal they have
different languages it's not Universal
and there was someone in our region who
like captured a child from the
uncontacted raised him in a very remote
community and people have tried
anthropologists have tried they've been
like hey so what was it like when you
grew up
and it's it's like it's dark he's just
like I don't remember like no one's been
able to get any information out of him
how old was he when they captured I
think like six like under ten for sure
does he not remember or does he just not
want to talk about it I don't know
that's that's that's the these there's
all there's all these underlying stories
um
oh man yeah that's just that's just then
last year some loggers went to a place
they shouldn't have gone and they got
they got whacked and uh sort of like the
you know like the WhatsApp underground
in Peru like everyone was sending each
other pictures because one of the cops
like sent to his family a picture of
what the bodies looked like on like day
six laying on the beach with arrows in
them and [__]
and it was like oh my God it was like
this it's just it makes you stay in bed
at night you're just like I'm not going
out
but I mean
yeah it's just it's a complicated topic
because there's people that want to
contact them there's people that want to
leave them alone and then of course
there's missionaries that are like they
need the Bible
what did you think about lost city of Z
um I loved the book
I wanted more from the movie
um of course yeah there's only so much
time and yeah
um Hollywood [__] yeah god
um the book was fantastic and that guy
was out of his mind out of his mind out
of his mind yeah uh Percy Fawcett yeah
Percy Fawcett but like the fact that he
could go on those Expeditions and not
get infected I've been I've been I've
been brutally like let me show you I'll
show you this picture I don't think
there's any way of pulling this up but
like
the
oh my God like the jungle just gets into
your skin what is that on your face uh
MRSA infection it like started it
started like you know mosquito bites and
then I would scratch and you don't
realize you're spreading it with your
fingernails and you like go like this
and [__] and sudden I mean I almost died
from that like that was but I was
staying in the jungle to like take care
of an anteater but it's like how did you
get free of that like if you're in the
jungle did you use antibiotics go um you
just go home I had to go home at that
point I got to I remember I got to JFK
and the the guy you know like looked
down my passport he goes yeah what were
you doing in Peru and then he looked up
at me he goes Buddy what the [__] and I
was like I'm just trying to Kevin and he
like stamped it he was like go go go go
go go he's like go go to the doctor I
can't I can't believe they let me
through right you could have been
infected with some crazy play could have
had like monkey Ebola like yeah it was
it looked bad
and I spent days in the hospital like it
was it was really really bad
um but for Percy Fawcett to not
they would say like other people would
be dying there was somebody I think the
guy's name was Murray he came from the
Shackleton XP already been out with
Shackleton so he was like I'm a real
Explorer and he lasted like he didn't
last any time with with uh with faucet
because Percy Fawcett was just like you
can't keep up go die you can go die with
them with the mules like he just
wouldn't stop
so my question is it's like did he go
out and eventually get killed or did he
eventually go out and like find the
tribe that made him their King and just
there's no knowledge there's no
knowledge of it yeah no one really knows
what happened to him and they said in
that book that over a hundred people
have died
looking for him since he left because
then the other Expeditions that have
gone out all of those have died too